hello everyone and welcome to another
video in our long awaited Capablanca
saga
sorry about the a bit of a long intro in
the previous video but without actually
hearing the story there's not much point
in watching the video I mean you could
just a load up a PG n and just check out
the moose but the story behind the game
is is basically why I started this
channel so I do hope you enjoyed those
as well now getting back to this match
like we said unorganized the match
between josé raúl capablanca and the
Kuban champion one course so the match
is still organized the first to achieve
four wins and capablanca is already down
two to zero so one course will won a
game with the white piece and a game
with the black pieces you already seen
one game work up a blank a lost he
failed to fend off that beautiful Evans
gambit game but then in the third game
kappa blanka managed to get a draw in
the fourth game kappa blanka managed to
get a victory he avoided the d Evans
gambit and went for the two Knights
defense and I will put a link to that
game in the description below if you
want to check that game out as well but
this is game 8 of their match it I chose
the game for two reasons I will get back
to that but it's it's the same line they
played in game 6 but it features an
improvement on capablanca Sparta part
but it's very interesting how that
improvement came to be so without
further ado let's check it out and if
you haven't checked the previous video
do check it out
and here is also a very nice photo of
the young Jose Raul Capablanca let's get
to it
again one course opens with E 4 as
you've seen he enjoys the Evans gambit
so he's a very creative and attacking
player kappa blanka replies 'if i've and
now we have Knight to c3 one course who
saw that he he no longer wants to go for
that Knight f3 business as Capablanca
will avoid the Evans gambit and go for
the two Knights defense and dare kappa
blanka play it played a very nice game
so ok we have knight c6 and now comes f4
we have the max lounge attack the vienna
game is on the board similar to the king
king's gambit but there is already a
knight on c3 so it's like the King's
gambit but a bit safer for white I
all white we'll still get plenty of
attacking chances but black will get a
less of a contract tacking chance as and
that was considered back then eke a
persona 4 kappa blanka grabs upon and
here kappa blanka says that constant
like one course will plays openings and
gambits as he knows capablanca never
grabbed an opening book so he tries to
catch him off-guard nice to have three
giving up on and now he will again very
strong control of the center and here
kappa blanka goes for g5 it's a standard
idea i like in the King's gambit when
you capture an F or you want to defend
your pawn with the g5 we have 84
capablanca pushes the pawn forward g4
and now comes Knight to g5 by huang
Corso also there's a similar idea in the
Kings gambit where if this Knight is
further attack black continues weakening
his King side then this night can be
sacrificed for this pawn on f7 and here
in some lines of the King's gambit you
can actually give up this Knight by
playing something like d4 or Bishop to
c4 but here it's it will not work after
pawn captures Queen captures simply
Knight e5 and then white will simply
have no counter play for for the for the
given material Knight captures Queen
captures and there is no compensation
for the sacrificed piece but okay
g4 nice - g5 and Capablanca once the
chase away the night the night has
nowhere to go
as the pawn is controlling all of the
retreat squares so it is obvious what
one course was next move will be Knight
captures on f7 we have King captures on
f7 and now comes d4 there's always time
for Bishop to c4 and here is one of the
reasons I chose this game here kappa
blanka plays the very act of d5 and
after the game 1 Corso told Capablanca
that instead of d5 it's better to play
d6 because modern upper opening theory
on the Vienna game suggests that black
has to play d6 here but couple on cos d5
move is the move that is preferred by
the engine when you analyze it today and
the engines favorite move is 3 actually
which leads to a very interesting game
but the deeper blue cover Blanca place
is also perfectly fine much better than
b6
in the given position but okay we have
he captures on d5 Queen to e7 check and
this exact same position was on the
board in Game six like we said this is
game eight of their match and in game
six one course was defended with Bishop
to e2 and that game ended in a draw but
after that game one course have said
that if he'd played the King to have to
the he would have won that game and
Capablanca didn't agree with the death
assessment of the position so he played
this exact same variation once again
thinking that maybe one course will go
for that King f2 line and then I'm gonna
try and refute it and indeed the
Concorso does go for King to f2 g3 with
check King to g1 and now you don't
really have a good Square for the night
if you try and save the night with nice
to d8 night b8 or let's say Knights the
before then after Bishop captures an f4
White will eliminate the g3 pawn as well
and the White will have an excellent
compensation for the sacrificed piece
but here after King g1 kappa blanka has
a different idea
he plays Knight captures on d4 he gives
back the piece for some excellent
counter play Queen captures some
DeForest played and here comes Queen to
c5 capablanca manages to exchange Queens
but there's also a problem for white
white can't just exchange Queens if
white captures the Queen then Bishop
captures on c5 Elise leads the checkmate
the King has nowhere to go as the g3
pawn covers f2 and h2 after Bishop
blocks
Bishop captures and e3 is checkmate so
one corso cannot trade Queens here he
has to figure out how to defend and okay
nice T to the queen is now defended and
Queen to b6 now the queen is nicely put
here the Queen still cannot on pin so
you cannot avoid the Queen trade if
needed kappa blanka can always capture
but for the time being he will simply
continue developing and there is the big
threat of Bishop to c5 winning the the
Queen's straight out so one core so
decides to trade here we have Queen
captures on b6 a capture some b6 and now
there's a there's a really big problem
here it's hard to find the move for
white you cannot capture la Poma and
therefore because you will still suffer
against the Bishop to c5 again leading
to checkmate Bishop to e3 Bishop
captures this will be checkmate
and other than that you can't move the
light square bishop you can't move the
King you can't move the rook we already
said the night can't really do anything
in the game nights the default was
played but this simply leads to to a
worse position
you cannot capture with the Bishop
Bishop to c5 still wins with a force
checkmate
so here Knights the d4 comes a with the
idea of blocking Bishop to c5
but then capablanca just pins no Knight
Bishop to c5 and ok c3 and now comes a
rope to a 4 it's very simple attack the
paint piece
there's no way to further defend the
night and again you cannot capture here
because it's the same idea if you
capture here with rook Bishop captures
and therefore now you suffer too
rook captures on d4 pawn captures and
Bishop captures leads to the same faith
Bishop e3 Bishop captures is checkmate
so after rook to a 4-1 courses so of
course even before this was on the board
that he will have to give up another
pawn so he plays Bishop to e2 at least
he will get some development in Bishop
captures on d4 we have C captures on d4
and now rook captures on d4 so from a
game that started out with one course
was sacrificing a knight on f7 for a
fierce attack
capablanca gave back material and now
we're in the endgame World Cup of manga
is just up to pawns so how will one
course will deal with this we have b3
preparing Bishop to b2 to attack hit the
rooks but Knight to f6
we have Bishop to b2 trying to trick
capablanca but rook to d2 attacking both
bishops and here comes Bishop to h5
check but Capablanca doesn't mind Knight
captures and h5 giving up the rook on h8
Bishop captures on h8 and now comes f3 a
very nice move as there's a very little
that can be done here the most important
idea is that it's frees DF for square
for the knight but also ideas like f2
are coming so you do have to capture the
pawn G captures on f3 split and now
comes Knight captures on f4 and here
there are so many terrible threats for
example if white continues
development let's say he goes rook 81
I feel free to pause the video here and
try to find it's actually a forced
checkmate in 7 but just try to find the
winning idea I don't have to or if you
feel like it you can calculate it all
the way for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent
checkmater in seven and for those of you
just want to enjoy the show
rook to g2 leads to a first mate King to
f1 now rook to F to check King to g1 and
now comes Bishop to h3 threatening all
sorts of checkmates and whatever why
does here it's checkmate you will either
suffer if you if you do nothing you just
push up on then you get nice to e to
check the King cannot move and after
rook captures then Luke to F 1 will be
checkmate or if you play something like
Bishop to e5 you can also go for a
different kind of checkmate nice to eat
- we'll go to checkmate but it's even
even a nicer one is rook to f1 check
forcing the King to capture as the bone
is covering the h2 square root captures
and now comes Knight to e2 again with
checkmate as the pawn and Bishop create
a wall here against the White King so
after Knight to f4 one course will tried
Bishop to e5 but now we get a similar
idea rook to g1 the rook to g2 check
King to f1 with a group to f2 check and
here if you go King to g1 then nice to
e2 is checkmate in one so one course of
played king t1 but here a couple Blanca
just play Knight to d3 check and it was
in this position that a one course or
resigned the game unmoved unmoved 26
whatever he does
if King b1 then you can either grab the
piece immediately or you can simply
improve g2 you attack the rook rook
moves and now you can capture Knight
captures on e5 and white white still has
two rooks against the rook and I tend
the bishop but there is no move for
white whatever you play now you can't
move the King the rook is controlling
the second-ranked it's pretty much
useless to move in you know the rooks
whatever you play Knight captures on f3
attacks the rook you're losing this rook
and it's the game is over
so yeah nice to d3 check an excellent
game by Capablanca which the black
pieces so as you can see
game game fork of a blank also one with
the black pieces in the two nights
defense here in game eight after after
three draws again a win with the black
pieces so young couple Blanca didn't
really care whether he played with the
white or with the black pieces he just
wanted to do you know exchange Queens
and then after that it was pretty much a
principled decision even that moment
where one Corso told him that's the
current opening theory suggested the d6
instead of d5 here after d4 that the d6
was the suggested move the principle
move is d5 you you're under attack
a white sacrifice material you want to
give back some material and go for some
rapid development force matters a
principle the decision by kappa blanka
and well the entire game is very very
principle than the very educational
so I do hope 93 I do hope you enjoyed
that and we're gonna cover a few more
games as there are quite quite some
interesting games from this match the
score is now 2 to 2 with with several
drawers so Blanca equalized in this game
8 but as the game the match still has to
be decided that the first four victories
so we're gonna check up a couple of more
games once again that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it really a spectacle
bomb by the by the twelve-year-old
Capablanca I would like to thank Tony
Clemens Alexander Broome the Daniel
Tupac you punky Herrera seen the anger
and Louie Blaine Munoz for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
with some more interesting josé raúl
capablanca
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon